ils sont venus prendre le pou de la
justice la cour d'appel de Versailles
accueille depuis mardi le plus haut
magistrat de France pour une mission
d'information ça consiste pour le
conseil à comprendre le mieux possible
le fonctionnement de la Cour d'appel les
différents problèmes auxquels la cour
d'appel peut être confronté accompagné
de H autres membres du Conseil le
premier président de la Cour de
cassation doit rencontrer et
s'entretenir avec des magistrats mais
pas que pour mieux comprendre nous
essayons de rencontrer le maximum de
personnes à la fois les chefs de la cour
d'appel le premier président et le
procureur général mais aussi la
directrice de Greff la directrice du des
services administratifs et c'est comme
ça que nous avons une idée aussi
complète que possible du fonctionnement
de la Cour d'appel ces déplacements ont
aussi pour objectif de remplir un rôle
majeur la nomination des magistrats
c'est le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature lui-même qui propose donc
qui choisit en fait
ceux qui vont occuper ces fonctions
c'est le cas par exemple pour un
président de tribunal un premier
président de cour d'appel ou quel un
membre de la Cour de cassation et puis
dans toujours dans cette activité de
nomination pour les autres fonctions le
Conseil donne un accord mais la
proposition est faite par le
gouvernement au cours de cette mission
de 3 jours la délégation s'est aussi
rendue dans les différents tribunaux
judiciaires qui compos la cour de
versaill ils s'étendent sur quatre
départements les ivelines les hautes
scènes leur et le
valdoise